vous entendez bien on
commence quoientend bien encore on
commence le film on a commencé il y a 3
jours alors ça va encore toute façon on
a l'habitude de vivre ensemble on av que
17 ans ensemble 18 ans
ensemble mais je crois que c'est à
Françoise non Catherine que vous devait
d'avoir fait du cinéma oui c'est exact
et qu'est-ce qu'elle m'en
veut comment ça s'est passé RAC ma
chérie et bien je tournais je devais
tourner les portes claques et dans le
film j'avais besoin d'une sœur et le
producteur Francisco m'a demandé si je
ne connaissais pas quelqu'un qui me
ressemblait beaucoup j'ai d si j'ai une
sœur qui me ressemble beaucoup oui enfin
enfin assez et c'est comme ça que
Catherine a commencé à faire du cinéma
et elle nit pas très content d'ailleurs
elle l'a fait parce que c'était les
vacances les grandes vacances parce
qu'on M a poussé j'étaé poussé dans ce
métier
oh quelle
toupagérable ça ça vous manque pas par
exemple d'avoir pas fait comme Françoise
le Conservatoire d'avoir suivi ce sera
vous de juger je peux pas
vous